[Music]
you've seen the Transformers scour the
universe seeking The Matrix of
leadership the all-spark the sun
Harvester with the Matrix of leadership
again the space Bridge the seed Merlin
staff and a bumblebee but nothing can
prepare you for where their desperate
search for the key will take them this
time
eat Earth it's always Earth there are no
planets besides Earth and Cybertron you
fool you absolute buffoon
Transformers rise of the beasts after
Michael Bay made you feel insane for 10
long years
and Bumblebee made you feel hope again
get ready to feel Nostalgia for a time
before live-action Transformers movies
because when a generic new Sky beam
thingy is discovered on Earth of all
places I mean can you believe it the
evil tarot cards will come to get their
precious key get the key well the
Autobots fight to keep the key preserve
the key no matter the cost protect the
keys guard the key do we have the key
the key but sometimes the reverse
happens protect the key
we use the transwarf key to visit young
worlds if you give us this key tomorrow
I will light the beacon but don't worry
the rest of the story is told with the
same delicate subtlety so y'all are
robots that transforming the cars even
though you're from way out in space but
now there's this key that opens the
portal back to your home and when you
know this because there's a Beacon Light
in the sky that I can't see because I'm
human everybody got that so you're
saying this thing Unicron eats planets
to survive yes through weeklier all
right so you're a maximal y'all are
Autobots what was those things that
attacked us earlier terracons you know
what they should just grow the wiki on
one side of the screen and play all the
monkey punching on the other deal
[Music]
meet Noah he's Miles Morales that's it
that's the character Noah is a dedicated
older brother from Brooklyn even my
brother
Avenue Brooklyn New York Elena is a
brilliant Museum intern from Brooklyn
Brooklyn
he represents Brooklyn while she was
raised out in Brooklyn I'm from Bushwick
I'm never leaving Brooklyn again
Brooklyn baby yes Brooklyn I was raised
out in Brooklyn Elena is armed with
knowledge about literally every field
from paleontology that's a good one but
the Ankylosaurus also armored dinosaur
to all of art history The DaVinci sketch
is legit
Sinners Creek curse tablet it would be
expensive but it's a fake I think it
might be Aztec or Inca to masonry that
stonework is 17th century two
hieroglyphics this symbol is definitely
not hieroglyphic to the geographical
layout of Cusco Peru somehow that's
Santo Domingo the Spanish builted on top
of an old Inca Temple and it's my first
time leaving New York hang on is he
carbon dating now she's an intern
keeping them safe is Mirage a
Transformer voiced by professional
tattoo Hammer Pete Davidson he's more
desperate for human approval than those
Dolphins they train to predict the Super
Bowl
there you go now we're friends but what
about for friendship in a character that
aimed for a combination of Bugs Bunny
and a mask but while he may not be funny
he is smoking
phew make sure you melt the voice box
real good too don't want him coming back
again
watch the evil Planet eating Unicron
float around evilly while he outsources
his villainy to the evil Scourge who
will Outsource his ability to a sad pack
of dogs kill the other human our only
hope is Optimus Prime but years of being
stranded on earth have turned him into
the racist Uncle the other Autobots
tolerate at family gatherings you
brought a human here I should have known
better than to rely on humans he's
joined by RC a motorcycle armed with NSA
government surveillance Powers private
fun and not at all like a cop bumblebee
who is also there
they're joined by the maximals the kind
of tool you get when you ask Mom for
Dinobots but she says you already have
Dinobots at home Joy these transforming
Robo animals that the movie forgets can
transform into the very final battle
but don't worry they'll get more to do
in the sequel what do you mean if this
even gets a sequel what do you mean if
movies even exist two years from now
we're kickstarting the Hasbro Universe
bro we're in the middle of an ongoing
war and we'd love to have you join the
fight you and your whole team see
somebody wouldn't promise a franchise
that they end up bailing on it'll be
total chaos thrill as Noah gets a power
suit made of his friend's corpse and a
handgun made out of his friends just
don't ask what part of my body it came
from huh kind of Cronenberg is for a
kids movie work friends you've been
inside me that's just engine oil huh
what is this crash shaping of the human
body by modern technology once Noah gets
his fresh new Corps sued watch a human
finally join the fight alongside the
Transformers rather than limply firing
an AR-15 at a Decepticon Tyree style
save yourself so ah
even though he still needs a lot of help
why don't they even bring humans along
at all humans can't fight a metal
gorilla humans can't even find a normal
gorilla I mean I could but that's not a
discussion you're all ready to have so
take a promotional trip down to
beautiful Peru enjoy the lovely scenery
and Charming local color get to know the
people and their ancient culture while
exploring the fascinating Incan Villages
and ruins that dot the entire landscape
of the country's Serene sacred Valley
ah Brew oh and watch Robots pull each
other's spines out with their bare hands
foreign
[Music]
that's my job
[Applause]
give me your face
starring
in the fight Optimus and the black
Messiah already dating Penelope Pitstop
Prime day Kong Perlman I drink and I
explode things like And subscribe this
is what Peak Performance looks like ah
the French champagne and there is more
to them than meets the eye
they said the thing
we fought a zoo
okay what are the rules
grows before hoes okay that phrase
in-game popularity until the mid-2000s
though you could argue that the first
use of the phrase was in common sense a
song in my own world in 1994 the senior
this film takes place however that album
didn't release until October and in this
scene you can clearly see the calendar
is set to June 1994.
and this is why nobody wants to talk to
me at parties
I am Optimus Prime and I stand with
sag-aftra monkey business is boobing why
fart and waste it when you can burp and
taste it roses are red my name is not
Dave this makes no sense microwave